So, wait. The video was ready on the 27th and then it was unchanged
for a week and then got released. Is that right? The Tuesday
before I left, bro. What? What? So, there's that whole week of
streaming doesn't get released and then it get just so happens
to get released on the first day that I'm away, bro. These
waited for me to go away, didn't they? It's so obvious, bro.
They waited for me to go away before releasing it. Oh my god,
dude. That is ridiculous, bro. And I'm the snake, apparently.
And I'm the [__] snake.
Okay. Where is
Should we just do the Chud video real quick? I think so.
We can just do that real quick. Chudlogic versus Nicholas Dioro.
The Nicholas Dioro video.
Total coward.
Now, is this AI or is this like meticulous Photoshop to get the
nose like perfect? Hello. >> I think that was really the
start of the end. That was the point at which people were like,
"Yeah, this chug guy can't really be trusted." I got an angry
DM from Nicholas. Nicholas was in my ear once again. So, he was
challenging the idea that I was. So, if you guys forget, basically
Nicholas Yorio went hard on Chud over his lack of turkey response
when Chud went on vacation. Chud had been saying he was going
on vacation. I think he started talking about it like a month
before he left, two months before he left maybe. People knew
Chud was going to Vietnam like months before he left for Vietnam.
And then he explicitly said, "Hey, if I'm on vacation, there's
been a rule he's stuck to in the past where he's like, "On vacation,
I don't respond to internet. I'm just on vacation." Okay. So
Tom posted a response after Chud left. And Chud didn't react
to it and Nicholas like went kind of hard on him and started
talking about just started talking all kinds of Okay. So Chud's
back from vacation now. He's very angry at Nicholas Dioro. He's
not happy with this guy. All right. >> Was a strange. Well,
you're telling me yes, I was a strange. I'll show it. [__]
you, Nicholas Dioro. Oh, yeah. By the way, I have had a problem
with YOU FOR MONTHS. [laughter] WHAT? THE John Wickham commentary
crying about people screenshotting his members Discord. They
waited for me to go away before releasing it. That is ridiculous,
bro. I don't know, dude. I guess you can make your own mind up.
But it does seem kind of suspicious.
It does seem
that there's been a little bit of while the cat's away, the mice
will play. Someone tried to cast a great >> How did Chud
know the Tom stuff was dropping two months in advance? That's
a great question,
dude. It's um this will be interesting. So, yeah, basically Chud
Logic, Nicholas Yoro in a big
uh could we call this a lover's quarrel? Like a breakup? They
basically they had a relationship that wasn't working for a long
time, but it was sort of like
simmering. Okay. the pot hadn't boiled over and then the pot
boiled over quite recently. All right.
Uh this this stream I think is going to be quite good. I I enjoyed
the clips I've seen from it. We'll see this 40-minute video how
well it does encapsulating the whole segment. If we miss anything,
I can go back for it. But this is nice to to watch this video
because then we've got a response from Nicholas Yoro as well
now. Okay. I've also got an imager album with all of the messages
from Nicholas Yorio's server about this video or about Chud's
stream here from that morning. Okay. So we can check it out.
shadow over my
Haven't you been in a one-sided cold war with Nick for over a
year now? Well, you think it's one-sided because you don't see
the angry messages that I get when I say something out of pocket
on stream. It seems one-sided to you, but it's not to me cuz
I get the little angry message. Um, Chad, Chad, um, you said
this thing on stream, Chad.
Yeah, dude. That's the other thing as well, man. Since when did
it become a noble act to be a bunch of mean girls? apparently
[laughter] did. They've all BEEN ABOUT ME FOR MONTHS. WHAT THE
[__]
And I felt this. I felt this energy. I talked about feeling strange
because all of a sudden no one wanted to [__] with
me anymore, which is fine by the way.
Also, there's the whole thing where if you like I think most
of us have been watching this, okay, most people who are here
like regularly would have followed along with this content. But
the another really big thing that was happening this whole time
is Tommy C who is in DMs and group chats with Nicholas and Auggie
and Turkey Tom and all these people, Willie Mack,
like Tommy C was just leaking from these group chats saying they
all hate you. They all hate you. They all hate you. And not a
single one of them ever came out and went, "No, that's not true."
It's like, I don't know if if I'm sitting there and one of my
friends is going, "Yeah, JTock. JTO hates you." If I don't feel
that way, I'm going to actually clear that up, right?
I don't I don't just let somebody say what my opinion is on another
content creator without saying anything. I I don't just let it
go. Tommy C is disgusting. No, I think every creator who didn't
come out and say, "No, Tommy's wrong." and also like tried to
keep the peace with Chud privately behind the scenes is a coward.
You're like totally cowardly for doing that
there. In fact, I I would say probably on Chud's side, there's
no reason he should have accepted that standard of conduct. He
should never have accepted people like doing the whole thing
where they're like, "Yeah, no, we're still cool, man. Everything
cool behind the scenes." While Tommy C is out there going, "Yeah,
uh they all talk about you behind your back. None of them trust
you. They all think you're a snake."
It shouldn't be acceptable to go in private and go, "Oh, no.
I don't think you're a snake, man. I just, you know, I had a
problem with this this one thing, but I don't think you're a
snake. It's like, we're cool, dog. But it's like they've all
been talking behind the scenes about me apparently talking [__]
about me. Why not just tell me, hey, I don't [__]
with you anymore. Why don't you say, "Oh, hey, I don't really
like that you said this. We can talk about it or not." And I
don't [__] with you anymore for that reason. To be
honest with you, I'm quite pleased this has happened cuz now
the band-aid is off and we don't need to play games anymore.
We don't need to pretend that we're all friends and everything's
tickly boo when there's unresolved resentment and tension. >> Incredibly
British. Incred tickity boo. I don't believe that. That's Chud
Logic trying to sneak a thing that no British person says. He's
like trying to sneak made up fake British vernacular past you.
I don't believe that. Tickety boo. No shot. >> Simmering
away. So it's good. Let's just rip the band-aid off and call
it what it is. Let's call a spade a spade then.
Dude, it's so annoying. I'm going to tiptoe around some bat losser
because if you say the wrong thing, they're going to get you're
going to get angry DM complaining to you about it. Dude, we don't
have to worry about that anymore, dude. He said his peace. He's
done his little move, hasn't he? Where he sort of criticizes
me whilst I'm away and now he can just ignore me. You mounted
an attack when he was sleeping. Mounted an attack. I said, "Oh,
the big sweep could be on." That was my mounting an attack. Who
talks about this and who doesn't?
Is a sign of something. That's mounting an attack apparently.
Dude, do you see >> me? people. Do you see the insanity
that people have got to where me saying things like that are
seen as some insane attack when it wasn't even that crazy, bro?
I didn't say anything that crazy. Dude, people are acting like
I was out here saying derange [__] Dude, do you do
you see the problem? Do you see what's happened here? There's
this insane narrative that's been perpetuated about me. None
of these have actually watched my coverage and they're just angry
at me. It seems like he's more an issue with your fans brigading
him when you first called him a sweeper and you're actually saying
that. The problem is it wasn't predominantly my fans. I mean,
was he even brigaded? I don't know. I I feel like this is classic
Darvo, to be honest with you. This is classic
uh everybody gets blamed for things Queman does. Okay.
Everybody gets blamed for it. That's that's how Nicholas operates
cuz Nicholas is terrified of Quean. Okay. He's absolutely terrified
of Queenman. He never ever directly goes at the guy ever. He
never does.
For for months and months and months, he would just try to go
against like go after somebody adjacent. He'd never go directly
at him. Scared to say his name, scared to bring him up all the
time, man. >> Daring this. >> Don't blame Chud for
Don't blame me for Don't blame anyone else for blame. Okay. >> Being
engaged in bro. My videos were getting [__] raped,
dude. Dislike bombed. [__] every comment was about
>> By the way, that's not Quean's fault. It's not like
Queman is saying it's not like Queman is trying to offiscate
who's actually saying these things. It's Nick. Nick is scared
to go after a strong target. He will never ever ever go after
a strong target ever. He only kicks people who are already down,
right? He sees that like Hassan [__] is getting like
brutally after the October 7th stuff. Hassan [__]
Hassan [__] Hassan [__] Hassan Piker's
numbers start coming back up. Oh, looks like he wasn't quite
so wrong on Israel. Oh, guys, I think the Hassan stuff starting
to go a little too far.
Good one. Good one, man. >> You're sweeping. You're sweeping.
You're sweeping. So, who's getting brigaded? Exactly. And again,
I don't give a dude. Leave your comments. This idea that like
he's some victim is so pathetic, dude. Let's get into it, guys.
This goes back. This goes way back, guys. [snorts] >> All
this business with Nick. Okay. Nick wants you to believe that
I had some crazy take about the Turkey Tom thing. wanted to make
a bunch of jokes about me sweeping because I didn't. >> Uh,
he doesn't want to see it, but it's gonna happen. Not a goofball.
It's just a matter of when.
It's not a matter of if, it's a matter of when. Okay.
It's going to happen.
The day the day Queen laps Nicholas and Concurrent viewers, I
I don't know what's going to happen then. Okay. Then he won't
even be able to do because I don't know if you've noticed this,
Nick is taken to a new argument, kind of like a Andrew Wilson
adjacent argument, okay? where he goes, "Well, all these content
channel, all these channels, they're just little they're just
little. They're just little and I don't have to deal with any
of them. It's not even a big deal." It's like, well, okay, we'll
fix that and then we'll we'll come back and see. We can still
have this conversation. God forbid a big channel make a Nicholas
Yoryo video. Man,
what is he what is he going to do then if big channels start
going in on him?
Well, he's gonna sense that it might be happening and then maybe
he's just gonna go
I guess
I I wish that world existed where people paid attention to this
stuff enough where a big channel would go in on him. But alas,
we're just waiting on
Dude, we're never mind. There's not going to be Who am I kidding?
There's never going to be a Nicholas Yorio video because it's
all Dude, if there's not even an Ethan Klein video yet, we're
never getting a Nicholas Yoro video. >> Cover his response
because I was on vacation. This all goes back to the New Year
stream. That's the reality of it. How much drama? >> That's
what I said. That's what I said yesterday. It's all about the
New Year's stream. I think it goes back to the New Year's stream.
Nice. >> Came off of the New Year stream, bro. How much
drama came off of the New Year stream, dude. So before the New
Year's stream started, Nicholas Big Nick Pigus FFW as I've heard
him before, [laughter] which I disappear
enough. If they didn't want to talk about the Destiny stuff,
I understood that Tom was in a position where he was kind of
stood in his orbit and all this and I was like, >> by the
way, Chud didn't bring that up on that stream.
He's just once they started talking about it, he just went, "Nope,
this is my opinion. I don't know what you guys are talking about.
I have a totally different opinion." And they're like, "Well,
I don't know about that." And and they disagreed. Okay. >> Okay.
Whatever. >> You don't want to talk about something, don't
bring it up and then disagree when he tries to differentiate.
Okay. >> Right. And I think Nicholas maybe had some wind
of like some of the stuff that was going on behind the scenes,
but then he bought it up on stream and then people started saying
stupid things about it. And me being me, I cannot sit there and
have people say stupid things about a topic that I disagree with
and bite my tongue. I have to say something about it. I have
to say something. I have to comment. I have to comment about
it, dude. I have to I have to speak. And I just felt like people
were just saying stupid things about it. So, I just said my piece
and challenged people a bit on it. Do you know what I mean? I
didn't ask the question. I believe Nicholas brought it up. And
the reality is that was like the start of it. That was the start
of my issues with these people because you know from there I
think Turkey Tom got like a B in his bonnet about me because
he felt that I was being challenging.
So he apparently turned out not liking me off the back of that
which I didn't really know or understand. Willie Mack a few months
later I think took issue with me challenging him about some of
his tweeting and some of his takes about the Destiny video that
he did. Again, something that wasn't really made clear to me
and it just was sort of left with us not really speaking anymore.
And then it turns out later during the Tommy C drama that Willie
Mack had some big issue with me apparently, right? And so I think
that was really the start of the end. That was the point at which
people
I Uh, it's so funny.
This all I swear it's like all downstream of them just not wanting
to talk to Queven basically.
I mean, it's a I feel like it's a little bit me. I always I wanted
a conversation with Nicholas after the original like, you know,
Willie Mack debate. It's a little bit me, but it's really downstream
of them just not wanting to talk to Queen like the whole time
and basically be like, well, Chud is telling Queenie to do these
things. It's just like, bro, you are writing fanfiction to avoid
talking to the guy. Okay, you're writing fanfiction about how
this guy's like setting stuff up behind the scenes. It's not
happening. >> People were like, "Yeah, this chug guy can't
really be trusted, you know? He's he's um I mean, I don't know
how they framed it exactly. >> How do you, By the way,
how do you do I I know Kim's here. He's not actually here. He's
like AFK, but um how do you do that Stardust tweet when when
these people all run from him?" It's like Stardust does this
tweet
like we do this tweet when Stardust is terrified of Quean. Nicholas
is terrified of Quean. They're both totally terrified of Quean.
They would never ever have any conversation with Queen ever.
It's like dude, are you serious? You're like talking this. You're
totally terrified of this person. Like you It's It's the way
she's talking. You just want to say this guy's like ugly or something.
Talk your Okay. But you're like trying to Oh, he's like he looks
sickly and he doesn't he tries to sound intimidating. You're
intimidated by him.
You're like trying to You're trying to pretend that he's not
scary, but you are terrified of this guy. You're absolutely terrified.
Petrified even. Okay. You and Nicholas both.
It's just crazy. Crazy to tweet when you're absolutely petrified
of the
>> that's fine. But I think from my perspective, I just
was a bit challenging on points. So yeah, I think that was the
start of it. But I still had like a friendship and a connection
with Nick, you know. I guess I guess like there's probably some
behind the scenes conversations that were happening that I wasn't
privy to, but I think it started this kind of like negative perception
of me that was being shared amongst these people. Obviously,
I've got no visibility of that and I can't see that, but that's
my perception and my belief is that they started to talk a bit
of [__] about me, you know. Um, and then a few months
later,
there is the immortal clip. There's [laughter] the immortal
clip. Oh, I I don't know why Todd isn't saying that during the
Tommy C thing. Like Tommy was literally saying
I I He's saying it sounds like he's just sort of inferring this.
Tommy was literally saying it and Nick refused to go up and say,
"No, no, no. That's not true. That's not true." Okay. That caused
tremendous
psychic damage. This clip
was, I believe, the dagger in the heart of our friendship, but
we didn't know it at the time. Is as dry as the Sahara, unless
you're willing to do the 20th stream sucking off and Clyde. Yes,
I'm talking about you, Nicholas Doria. Okay. Is this, ladies
and gentlemen, was the start of the end for me and Nick. I'm
afraid to say in hindsight now, I can see it all so clearly.
We ended up putting this up as a segment. Okay, at the time I
had Nicholas in my DMs complaining about this stuff to put it
simply. And the thing is I did like Nicholas and I did value
what he'd done for me and I didn't want to get into a big blowout
fight with him over Ethan Klein coverage.
So
I said, you know, maybe we can have a conversation at some point
and how By the way, I'm just going to go ahead and throw this
out there. If Nick's not a Nick should just leak out anything
he knows about Chud behind the scenes. Okay, let's uh let's light
this candle. Okay, if if Nick knows anything, I think Tommy was
hinting at stuff. Anything you guys know, can you guys just leak
whatever you got? I just I want content. Okay, I'm very lazy.
It's been a crazy January. It's been a crazy January and February
of 2026.
Why not go into March with like everybody leaking everything
on everyone? Okay, let's go. No secrets. March is the month of
no secrets. If Nicholas Dioro has anything, leak it immediately.
Okay, leak it now. some of this stuff out privately privately
because I knew that he wasn't really keen to come on stream and
I wasn't necessarily keen to have like an on-stream conversation
at the time either, right? I didn't follow up on that. I didn't
follow up on that and we didn't end up speaking off the back
of that privately. And from there, I guess we've just had like,
you know, occasional backwards and forwards DMs, but nothing
particularly crazy. just occasionally touching base on this drama,
that drama, but then it got to a point for me when to be honest
with you, it just felt like the friendship was just kind of a
husk.
The friendship was just kind of like a husk basically. And honestly,
it felt like the only time that he reached out to me was almost
like touching base, almost like checking in, you know, almost
like checking in to see is he still on my side? Is he still going
to kind of like,
you know, be be relatively reasonable? Is he going to turn on
me or something like that, right?
So, it just felt like it was a bit of like a game.
You guys know the uh
you guys know the the puppet strings meme of like the increasingly
like large puppets with the strings.
There needs to be one that's like um
is it like Chud and then that goes up to like uh
that goes up to Queman Queen doing the puppet strings and then
that goes up to like Stylo and then that goes up to like DK and
then that goes up to like Boots and then I don't know who's above
that. Like maybe Deeperama or something. I don't know. We need
like that meme happening. Okay, with the Chud stuff that Nicholas
Dioro thinks that like Chud Logic is his enemy but that's not
his enemy. There's like an enemy a far deeper
enemy. Okay. far a far larger enemy that exists above all of
those that's pulling strings. All
I I hope I hope we can get that domino effect. Yeah. >> We
had this friendship, but it wasn't really a friendship. >> It's
like that's like how I see it. I don't know. I I I know almost
nothing about the relationships between those people. By the
way, uh just just throwing it out there as like a original like
I don't know some kind of idea about it. Okay. >> I felt
estranged.
I felt like he didn't really like them anymore. at the top >> and
no one else. >> You don't you don't get to develop a level
of anti-semitism like Deepama has
being like the uh I think I've said this he's like the the harmonious
frequency to whatever the dreams are putting into the universe.
Okay. He's like he's like on a on a harmonious frequency. It
like it it vibes. It's very different. It is antithetical too.
It is totally out of step with but it is harmonious. Okay. It's
doing some of the same things. >> Like me anymore. But
I couldn't really put my finger on it. I couldn't really put
my finger on it. And that was kind of it really. So it got to
a point where I just stopped responding to him. And he would
send me a DM and be like, "Hey." Or like, you know, something
like that. And I just stopped.
Hey man, are we okay? Hey, are you good? Hey, uh I Hey, what's
up? Did you catch the new episode of Game of Thrones? What's
Are we good? >> Responding to him. >> I could believe
that. I could believe that. some comments about him to Pisco.
Do you remember that?
I made I made some comments to Pisco about how much Nick blocks
people and that I felt estranged.
And guess what I got when that started getting shared on social
media? I got an angry DM from Nicholas, didn't I? I got an angry
DM from Nicholas. Nicholas was in my [__] once again.
You say the truth about Nicholas, he just gets really mad. It's
cra like he just gets really angry about it. What the [__]
man? Dude, you you blocked Dickers for for just showing that
what what did Dickers even show that like something about the
Mudahar engineer comments? Dickers like just literally went and
and like did some quick check on I can't remember if it was a
Doryo video or a mud. It was something. Dickers basically like
verified a fact and disagreed with Nick on something and got
blocked.
Like it's the the level of sensitivity
Nick engages in is crazy. He had even less reason to block Pisco.
Yeah, I have no idea why he would have blocked Pisco. I just
he like he he he blocks with a total hair trigger, which is fine.
Just don't get mad if other people mocked you for blocking with
with a total hair trigger. Why are you getting mad about it?
Ch just said something totally accurate about you. Nobody was
shocked when Pisco was like, "Who's this Nicholas Yoyo guy and
why did he block me?" Literally zero people were shocked.
If you expect people not to mention that, okay, you're going
to have a rough time on the internet. >> Chud, I've tried
to be your friend. I've tried to message you. What are these
comments that you're making? Right. >> Once again, I
>> Hey, Chud, I just wish you were like responding to me.
Uh, you didn't even respond to me when I asked you if you're
doing okay. >> Try to play the Peacemaker cuz [laughter]
this is the thing with Nicholas Dioro, dude. This is the problem.
Okay. He wants to have a private conversation to cool things
down. And I, to my discredit, criticize me for all this if you
want to. I've allowed that to happen. And I've been like, do
you know what? I do like Nicholas. I do appreciate what he's
done for me. I don't want to get into some [__] fight
over this. Okay.
[clears throat] Yes, I have been a I have been a Call me a Certainly.
Certainly. Yes. Okay.
>> Do you remember when uh Chud and I had that whole DM
leak thing? Oh, never mind. I'm not going to bring it up. There's
like
there's like a little thing there that's not even consequential,
but he asked me to leave like uh
he like
we we sort of came to an understanding on that. We were cool
after that. Okay. But um
I think he basically asked me I was kind of mad at him for doing
it and he just he wanted to make sure Nicholas was fine. He just
he he was like more worried about Nicholas in that situation
than himself. He like actually cared about Nicholas's reputation,
how people viewed Nicholas more than anything. I think he like
actually was concerned about Nick in that situation. I'm not
even joking.
And
it was just
it's just up that Nick couldn't see that or be like a >> I
don't know. >> And here's the thing. I see people saying,
"But you ignored him." But you ignored him, right? So when he
came to me and said, you know, you made these comments on stream.
I said, "Well, yeah, I feel a bit estranged."
Obviously, none of the commentary guys like me anymore, which
kind of sucks, right? It kind of [__] sucks.
And then Nicholas reveals to me, and I didn't actually know this
at the time, he said that he'd gone sour on me over this stuff
and how we'd spoken privately and I hadn't followed it up. So,
he was challenging the idea that I was estranged. And it's like,
well, you're telling me yes, I was estranged. You're telling
me yes, I was aranged [laughter] because you upset me with this
and how you handled it afterwards
that I didn't really want to [__] with you anymore.
So I said to I said, "Listen, we don't have to have a big blowout
fight. If you got some issue with me, we can just go our separate
>> Do you think this would have happened if Chud hadn't
forgotten that he said he would call in private after the H3
thing? I don't know. You're not that far, Ginger. If you know
the history of Nicholas and Chud arguing, this is the clip of
Chud calling Nicholas out for sucking Ethan Klein's when content
was dry. And apparently Nicholas got mad about this and wanted
to have a private call about it like back then. and Chud said
he forgot to follow up. So, if you if you know the history of
these two fighting back and forth or the little snipes they've
been taking at each other, then you're all the way caught up.
You're good to go.
So,
uh I don't know, going back to this comment, I don't know if
this would have happened if Chud called him. But
the the problem is Nicholas doesn't want you to say true things
about him, even in a joking sense, that like could anyway make
him look worse. And while I understand that that's like a position
you can have,
I don't think it's like actually reasonable to expect people
not to say little funny like if it if the moment's there for
a joke that you could do a little joke about something. You could
have like maybe one or two pet issues. If he wanted to say to
Chud as a friend, I just don't like it when people call me fat.
Could you not call me fat on stream? I I think it would be okay
for Chud to honor that, right? In terms of like not saying true
things, but like oh you're you're like kind of a you block people
automatically on Twitter. You say that about yourself. You know
you block people automatically on Twitter. How the [__]
are you gonna get mad for Chud laughing about it in another call?
You know that you overdo the Ethan Hassan Destiny stuff. The
the Ethan you you were like a huge sweeper for Ethan. You know
that. Why do you get mad if people just point it out, bro?
Felt like just last month that Nick was donating to Chud. That's
crazy. Well,
trust me, it's going to get worse. It's going to get crazy today
and that can be the end of it. We don't have to have a fight
like you always do. and he seemed at least somewhat accepting
of that and he said, "Well, good luck with whatever you're doing
over there." Or something like that, right? It was it was a bit
like, "Okay, well, that's a bit weird, but okay, I guess that's
that then. I guess we're just not going to, you know, play any
games anymore and just go our separate ways." Toxic rel.
>> Yo, I uh I started another segment doing the Chud stuff.
Okay.
>> Did you Did you see the Stardust tweet?
>> What Stardust tweet? >> Oh, you?
No. Yeah.
I'm putting you on the spot here, but it's like not It's literally
just saying you you look like you're a sick a sick child or something.
But I just think it's like
>> She literally looks like that fish. She looks like the
fish that got voted the ugliest fish in the world. You know,
you know that fish.
>> Blobfish. A blobfish. >> That's the one. That's
the one. >> Yeah. Yeah. I do be like that a little bit.
I just think it's hilarious where it's like imagine a man dying
from chalera from the middle ages tries to sound intimidating.
We won't forget
like you're actually intimidated by him. I've said you don't
have to respond to but you're actually intimidated. So like it's
weird when you say this. You're actually terrified to talk to
the person >> like she breaks about me to people behind
the scenes. She was going through like some OCD crisis from getting
rid of her dad or whatever the happened to her.
>> Jesus Christ. Yeah. Not shocking, but I'm Dude, it's
I I just don't understand. She's trying to rewrite
like after the fact, pretending that she's not terrified and
that she's not responding. You're literally talking to Nicholas,
who is also terrified, who's also like will not have a conversation
with you. I It's just weird that like you're trying to sound
intimidating. You're objectively intimidated.
I rolled that into just the whole reason like Chud is getting
or the the reason like Chud I I think the reason the Nicholas
Bridge burned is cuz Nicholas is upset about you ultimately more
than Chud and he just doesn't want to say that cuz he knows it
sounds gay to say it so he's not even willing to say it to Chud.
I feel like [laughter] I feel like it's it's all the same thing
anyway. And then after that, the Turkey Tom stuff happened and
I think it just set the grounds for Nicholas to take great issue
with me talking about the big sweep perhaps being on. He took
that very personally
and yeah, he went into this massive um tirade privately after
that stream. Felt very much like, you know, like this is going
to be the constant flow with Nick. It's that I'm going to make
some comment on stream and he's going to come angrily to me privately.
We then have a private conversation, resolve it, but nothing's
really resolved and there's still this underlying tension. And
those messages were the first time that I realized he'd had this
problem with me about this and how it happened afterwards for
months. So yes, I was estranged. I was estranged. None of the
other commentary guys like me anymore. And Nicholas had this
issue with me for months that he hadn't really expressed
and just hadn't really kind of been honest about. So yeah, it
was just this kind of unending underlying tension. Dude, this
idea that I'm some snake when people are waiting till I go on
holiday to start talking all this about me. Are you serious,
dude? Literally, what have I done wrong here? What have I done
wrong? How am I Dude, it's insane. It's insane, dude. I'm responding
to some deranged attack that this fat loser made about me when
I was on holiday and wasn't really in a position to respond.
Okay, fine. I'll show it. [__] it. [__]
it. I'll show it. [__] you, Nicholas the Oreo. [laughter]
I'll show it.
Okay, I'm going to read the DM to you guys here real quick. Wait,
maybe he is. >> Here we go. Here we go. Here's the [__]
interaction. So, this is obviously an example of me not responding
to him. I just saw a clip of you saying, "Um, I don't like you
anymore, but you haven't answered a DM from me since September
lau. I did try to keep coms open. >> Hey, man. Yeah, I've
been having a lot on. Honestly, it's difficult to know what the
deal is. We've gone our separate ways in many ways and obviously
it does feel a bit no one really likes me anymore from the commentary
space. I do probably have issues with some of your coverage,
but I don't want to keep talking about HD and honestly, I've
always appreciated you and the things you've done for me. So
I make snarky jabs from time to time to signal that I disagree,
but I don't want to blow up the little bridge we have by going
full skits and attacking you. I guess I feel estranged
just to be so I feel estranged. I feel like he doesn't really
like me anymore. I do like Nicholas and I have been friends with
Nicholas and I do appreciate what he's done. Yes, I know. Yes,
I'm going to get a lot of for this. It's fine. It's fine. Say
your peace. I'm a whatever you want to say. Just to be perfectly
transparent, this conversation sed
to be Nick in chat or
I assume that was Nick in chat, right? >> My perception
of you. So, he's talking about something that happened what in
May. In May 2025.
So, he's had a problem with me for months.
Hasn't said it to me. I've then felt estranged and like we're
not really friends anymore. And he's telling me now in 2026,
oh yeah, by the way, I have had a problem with you FOR MONTHS.
WHAT? SO, YEAH, THAT'S WHY I FEEL strange then cuz you had a
problem with me for months. Like he's acting like, well, I still
tried to message you. Yeah, but you didn't like me. You had a
problem with me and didn't say anything to me. So, I was right
to feel strange, bro. Dude, and then apparently as well,
on top of that, too. Apparently, Nicholas has been talking about
me as well. He's been talking about me behind the scenes, too.
And that's where some of the Tommy C stuff came from. Why did
you let this fat Lea read you via DMs? Because I'm too nice.
Because I'm too nice, bro. I'm too nice all the time, dude. So,
on my perception of you, I have many. Oh, that's that. You got
to watch that. I I try not to do that even if I feel that way.
Okay.
No, try not to say I'm just too nice. Usually that's not the
case. >> Friends on an ecosystem I disagree with. Make
different content than me. That was never an issue. Despite this,
I did attempt to keep the bridge open regardless.
So yeah, I mean that backs up the feeling of feeling strange.
It's all good. I'm not mad or anything. Things change. People
do different things. Listen, man. Everything has to be some catastrophic
breakdown. I know you're used to that. He was like typing here,
I think. And I just thought, okay, well, let's just [__]
call it a day then and go our separate ways.
Yeah, man. Good luck with whatever you're doing over there.
And that was that. In the new year stream, you put Tom in a corner
to talk about things he knew about privately regarding the situation
in a public manner. Bro,
I love the little rewrites of history that are happening here.
Um I
do you guys remember that conversation we had where I was like
arguing with Aiden about exactly what this was and like how it
happened?
Oh man.
I feel like if I feel like we went back and litigated that, I
I don't think I was totally wrong there. I just I couldn't go
back and say um like basically I think the lynch pin of this
was was when Nicholas figured out or or got DMs like regarding
this drama and I'd read some message from Chud that made me think
it was at one time and Nick said that wasn't true and I never
bothered to go back because it just wasn't something I cared
to argue and so I was like oh well I guess that changes stuff
fine and
I feel like
[__] it's like totally inconsequential but I I think
Nicholls was very concerned that people were worried that he
was going to get called a sweeper or something at that point
in time. I think that was his like number one concern was that
people were going to call him a sweeper over the Destiny stuff
and
I feel like he was aggressively managing that the whole time.
I don't know. Very >> Oh, I put anyone in a corner. >> I
called me right after he found out
the video was coming out. Um to be like, "Oh, son rat me. Everyone's
gonna say I'm I'm sweeping."
It's very gay. >> I think he was super concerned about
that. Yeah.
>> Challenging people that were saying things about topic.
I didn't put anyone in the corner, dude. Tom put himself in a
corner by saying things about the Destiny stuff. I am a softy,
bro. I am a softy. And also, I don't want to [__]
have some blowout fight over Ethan Klein coverage. You know what
I mean? But that's the problem is that's been my feeling about
it. It's not worth having some blowout over this. But Nicholas
didn't agree. Nicholas rather than say play me what he felt or
hop on a stream to talk about it or whatever he wanted to do
has been holding this and seething for months and then it all
came out with a turkey Tom drama because I talked some not even
necessarily all about Nicholas by the way people want to act
like my entire comment was about Nicholas this whole sweeping
thing dude I was yes obviously on stream I was being provocative
right and I was talking about maybe the big sweep's going to
be on or something like that but I made it very clear in follow-up
tweets that I was also talking broadly about the space and I
was talking found an obvious resistance to cover the Turkey Tom
stuff. People want to now act like Turkey Tom's response, which
is apparently good now, somehow undermines the point that I made
about there being a hesitancy to speak about it in the first
place. And it just doesn't. It just [__] [laughter]
doesn't, bro. In fact, if anything, looking at the response to
Turkey Tom's response only proves my point [__] further,
dude, because every channel has picked this up like that. The
second the responses dropped, everyone's on it like white on
rice. Everyone's making a video about it and talking about it
because Tom is perceived to have responded well to the allegations.
So all this commentary acting like, "Oh, Chop was so wrong about
this." No, I was correct. There was an obvious hesitancy to talk
about to not talk about the allegations when they first dropped.
Okay, now that could be for a number of reasons, but there was
an undeniable hesitancy and massive channels didn't pick it up.
But they did pick up the response. But they did pick up the response
very quickly, didn't they? They did pick up the response very
>> Uh, I think this is true, but I I do think Chud was
like going in on the like, oh, I I'm feeling like the sweep is
going to be in and he was a little he was a little I think over
the top within the first I don't know 24 hours,
>> but it's kind of sees he's like calling out the pattern.
>> Yeah, exactly. I can see why you think it was like uh
super premature if like you're coming into like totally cold,
but it's the Kai thing. It's the Kai thing that's fueling all
this is that because every literally everyone knows like Aiden
was told to like ban people and not address it if it gets brought
up and all this lyrics was like on GR for like over a year and
they refused to explain it and then it got started getting brought
up on Chud's stream and it's like that that's obviously sort
of what set the stage for this is Tom in the past has aggressively
through the gay little cabal tried to you know shut down any
of his little gay personal drama that leaks out with EOS
and other content creators.
>> That's interesting. I hadn't thought about the the lyrics
thing at all with regards to this, like the the Kai thing, the
whole cheating thing. >> Well, that's like obviously in
the back of everyone's head, that's what the sweep has come from.
That's why everyone thinks they're going to sweep this is because
they have with Tom before.
>> Interesting.
Interesting. Um,
Yeah. I think I I kind of just felt like, you know, it was also
just a joke and like a meme about them sweeping stuff, right?
Like even arguing obviously laugh about you know other >> more
substantiated by
the Kai thing. I think that is what Chud in the back of his head
is is thinking about >> is uh that that was like you know
the fas was it like the first few times he spoke to Tom or was
it maybe a little bit further into talking to all those guys?
I don't know. But they got brought up a lot on like streams.
It was one of the second, third, fourth time. It wasn't the first
time. >> It was like Tom was on for something or something.
Yeah. >> I I do think the way brought that up >> that
was a little uh I you could tell Tom was super thrown off by
that. >> I feel like when when he made the comment, you
could tell Tom was like, "Bro, what the like I I could tell for
sure." It's one of those things where it's like, oh man,
there's like comparisons in media where it's like the I don't
know like the the person I think it was like a like maybe a rich
kid at like high school is not used to getting talked down to
in a certain way and kids [laughter]
talk [__] >> and it's like it was like that
kind of vibe where Tom just didn't know how to process somebody
like saying bad like disrespect game like that on stream.
>> Yeah. That's the vibe I got.
Now, why do you think that is? Why do you think it is that some
of these channels that could have covered the original allegations
but didn't bother and instantaneously covered the response? Why
do you think they've decided to do it that way? This like I get
I get it, right? I get the meme. Oh. Oh, Chud. Oh, you were calling
everyone a sweeper, but now you're on. Yeah, I
I do feel like and I know I sound schizophrenic. I have no proof
for this. In the back of my head, I'm like, "Yeah, any of the
bigger channels that were like hesitant or like super on Tom's
side at the beginning, I do feel like uh they probably just got
a message with like, yeah, Tom's gonna respond to this and it's
going to be it's going to be he's going to blow it out. So, have
faith." I that's how I feel. Queen doesn't co-sign that, by the
way. That's how I feel about it with some of the bigger like
commentary YouTube channels, just like the people who do the
video essays, the daily commentary slob. I feel like probably
a couple of those people got messages just being like, "Yeah,
he's going to respond. It's going to be good. I think a lot of
people got messages. Yeah, I would say messages. >> Okay.
I was I I know what my intuition >> Schizosphere. So I
Yeah, I just had to make sure I differentiated.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So
you're not covering the response video. Aren't you kind of a
sweeper, dude? Well, I get it. I know it's fun to be smug, even
if it's not really honest and correct, okay? Because it doesn't
really get to the heart of what I was talking about. But can
we be [__] honest about something? Do people really
think that I wouldn't have covered the allegation if I was streaming
the Wednesday after it [__] dropped? That would have
been the first thing that I [__] spoke about. Have
So, so these people like I It's weird that Nicholas now streams
a lot and he seems to still not understand that. Like, bro, it's
when there's content, you just do the content. Like, did you
really There's no way you could possibly say Chud's not going
to cover this or something. Like, that's that's like the most
related content the day it comes out. Of course, he's going to
cover it. What are you talking about?
This is so wild to say, "Oh, well, I guess well, I mean, it's
pretty obvious what he was doing." But dude, everybody covers
If there's a big video, everybody's covering it, man. You just
got to That's the way it works. Having covered it so extensively,
but people want to do this gay meme where because I was pointing
out that people weren't talking about the video initially of,
"Oh, well, now you're not talking about this response, so you
must be tweeting." First of all, question. Was it planned? Was
it planned? Possibly. I've got no I don't know if there's good
evidence of that, but the timing is very convenient. >> You
kind of [__] up, JTO. You cutie
>> midway through answering your question about whether
they delayed it.
>> Did I? I didn't mean to do. >> Yeah. I've gone
back and looked at the clip and you ask him, "Did you delay it
for Chud's vacation?" And he goes, he says, "I don't know. Ch
was pretty quick to call us a sweeper." And then you jump in
with another question like a
>> what can you do
sometimes? That [__] happens, man. Live stream >> [__]
dropped second. >> I should have realized in the moment
to be honest. I should have brought it back up, but I only realized
we're watching the clip.
>> I
Yeah, I don't know why I would have let that go. Normally I'm
Normally I have like a kind of state machine in my head for things
that I need to know and I I can't really get away from them.
So, I don't know why I would have done that to be honest with
you.
>> Like just when I'm thinking through stuff, I just have
like certain questions that are really I know are like tangible.
I need to know them to for my opinion.
>> Oh well. >> Well, I kind of doubt I kind of doubt
he would have just said, "Yeah, we delayed it for Chud." Like,
>> I kind of, you know, we could have, you know, we could
have grown a little bit. We could have put a little bit pressure.
>> Would have given more information would have been helpful.
Yeah, sure.
And then all these people start banging on about, oh, charge
sweeping, charge sweeping, charge sweeping. I don't know, dude.
I guess you can make your own mind up, but it does seem kind
of suspicious. Also, the other thing I want to point out with
this ridiculous and deranged tirade that Nicholas has gone on,
there was nothing stopping Nicholas from doing this when the
allegations were happening originally before the response came
out. You know that me and Nicholas had a massive debate in our
DMs on Twitter about this topic.
We also had a debate, me, Orgie, and Nicholas in a group chat
as well. And this was around the time this was happening. Nicholas
was complaining about me swinging his audience into him. And
we had a big backwards and forwards and talked about it at length.
We had a big backwards and forwards at length. I can't show Well,
I could show the Twitter DMs, but I don't want to leak all the
Okay, I don't want to leak all the
DMs. And some of them I can't because it's a group chat. And
it's like, you know, there's been leaks from that group chat
before. And [laughter] there's been leaks from that group chat
before. Here's the one that Salvo leaked. is the one that Salvo
leaked.
Listen, I don't want to be in the same footsteps as Salvo. Okay,
huge Ty Ray. He talked a little. Stop being in your feelings.
Okay, this is Coke, dude. He launched a deranged
what 40-minute segment or something. I saw talking about me and
talking about me when I was on holiday when I was away. And it's
all stuff he could have spoken about before I went away. He could
have spoke about all of this before. We'd spoken about it privately.
We'd spoken about it in our DMs. We've spoken about it in this
group chat. >> So, one thing that you know for sure
is that
like what Chud's saying here, they had the disagreement and Nick
saw the video provably before Chud went on vacation. So, like
there's no reason Nick couldn't have levied these exact allegations
that said these exact things. This is 100% true, right? Like
Nick had all of the information to just go in on Chud. He could
have even got in on Jud like no matter what and he >> Right.
The Tom's response doesn't really change the dynamics of what
I was saying beyond some smug posting about the sweeping stuff,
right? [snorts] But the re the reason is the reality is okay
and here's why for some people this has seemed so like what Nicholas
is cutting CH off over this. What? Huh?
It's because it's not really about the Turkey Tom stuff. Okay.
Nicholas, as you saw, has had a problem with me for months. He's
had a problem with me for months. He's had a problem with me
taking little jabs about the EHD and saying little bits and pieces
here and there and talking. And so, he's waited and waited and
waited and waited. He's waited until I've gone away on holiday
so he can do his little gay trick that he does where he burns
the bridge. The person can't really respond immediately. Okay?
And now he can just go, "I've dealt with that. I've dealt with
that." And doesn't have to address or talk about anything if
he doesn't want to. Maybe he will. I don't know.
Yes, I took some jabs at him. Dude, when did it become so valorized
to be a hyper sensitive cowardly dude? What is this? Oh, you
were taking jabs at him, bro. It's the community, bro. That's
what happens. You talk about each other. You call each other
all sorts of names. You call each other all sorts of names and
you have some talk about some forwards and then you hash it out.
You maybe talk about it on stream, make a bit of content out
of it and move forward.
Chud, I I seriously feel like it's just
Chud that it's just so obvious they have like a hierarchy and
Chud taking shots like up that hierarchy is not allowed. Like
Chud Chud questioning the people above him like don't you know
we're above you actually. You don't get to do
I It It just seems like they're very clearly not feeling like
their peers at all. It's evident in everything Nicholas says.
Oh well, I came down like you know the heaven sent [laughter]
the
Heaven sentent Italian. Okay. Like a little like a little cherub.
A little Valentine's cherub. Okay. He came down from heaven and
saved resurrected Chud's channel right when Chud was about to
die. Like the way he talks about it, it's like he's just clear.
It's so clear. He thinks he's like above him. It's weird as man.
And move forward and that's the end of it. It doesn't have to
be a big deal, but for Nicholas it is. And dude, Nicholas takes
jabs at people all the time, bro. But he can't hack it, dude.
How many people is this loser blocked on Twitter, bro? How many
How many pe How many people in chat have been blocked by Nicholas
Dioro? How many people in chat have been [laughter] blocked by
Nicholas Dioro on Twitter?
How many people have been banned from his This is the egregious
thing is that Nick got mad about that of all things. Like the
thing Nick says himself, Nick talks about how he bans people
or blocks people on Twitter at the drop of a hat. How how the
you going to get mad that Chud points that out?
>> Like it's just obvious. It's obvious to >> He's
a thin skinned cowardly.
He cannot take it, dude. He He is the classic example
of he dishes it out and he can't take it.
He [clears throat] can't take the heat, bro. Why do you Okay.
>> Oh, real quick. Are we going to Aenai? You want to do
dungeons or something?
>> Um, yeah, sure. Sounds good.
>> Okay, I'll try to set this up and react to this at the
same time. >> Answer me this. Answer me this. Why did he
wait until I was on holiday to talk about me using material that
was already out for weeks? The stuff that he was talking about
was stuff I'd streamed roughly when the Turkey Tom allegations
first happened.
Why didn't he talk about it then? Well, he did talk about it
then because you know what he did? He came to my and was moaning
at me about it. We had backwards and forwards about the whole
thing twice. Twice we privately spoke about this sweeping twice
privately. One to one and in a group chat. He waited for Turkey
Tom's response so he could create this impression that I'd been
undermined by it, which is ridiculous as you'll see in a minute.
Okay. And then he obviously waited until I was away so that he
could launch his attack against me, say all the [__]
that he wanted about me, and then go, "Yep, that's dealt with.
Bridge and then not have to deal with any of the blowback." It's
so obvious, dude. It's so transparent. He is a conflict avoidant,
hypersensitive,
dude. And he has been for months and months and months at this
point. He does not want to be challenged. He does not want to
be challenged on any of the that he's doing. Okay. He is suckling
shekels out of Ethan Klein's like nobody's business. Jesus Christ.
Why? Why is Why is it shekels though? Why Why did he say shekels
though? Okay. Nobody show this clip to Ethan Klein. That'll be
a defamation lawsuit immediately. Okay. Why
>> did you know that?
>> Okay. [laughter] Well,
I don't know what other kind of lawsuit it could be. Okay. Just
go far a bunch of clips of Chud saying racist sent to the UK
police.
>> Uh Chud and what's the other guys? Chud and Dankula
sharing a cell together. Let's go.
>> I'm playing a Shatrath here.
How many bars into 65 are you? >> Not even one. >> Okay.
And the moment someone starts challenging too much on it, he
cuts it off. It's done. It's done. He doesn't want to [__]
hear it, bro. He doesn't want to [__] hear it, bro.
Okay. He's done it with other people and now he's done it with
me. Do you know one of the things that we spoke about in DMs,
right? I in a joking way I made a bit of a joke about it, but
I floated the idea of maybe having a conversation on stream about
this stuff, the EHD stuff, all of it, all of the [__]
that's been going on over the past few months because I figured
there seems to be no way to resolve this tension that's between
us. So, I thought we could go our separate ways, but apparently
not. Apparently, that's not possible. So, maybe that's the only
way. Maybe that's the only way we could actually resolve this.
And he said he didn't want to have a gay conversation about the
friendship allegations, but he would perhaps talk to me about
the Turkey allegations if he covered it in a way that I disagreed
with or something like that. And now obviously I'm assuming he's
never going to talk to me again. That's my guess. Do you actually
have a problem with him farming? No, I do not have so this another
thing I just want to debunk. Okay, this idea that I've got a
problem with people farming things. Okay, there is no I've never
met had an issue with someone farming the out of something. Okay,
I do not care if someone farms a topic to the ends of the earth
as long as there's honesty and credibility in doing that. Right.
As long as there's honesty and credibility in doing that. Do
you >> and that you can make fun of them for doing it?
Come on. >> Nicholas Dioro's Ethan Klein coverage has got
honesty and integrity. I'll ask you and you can [__]
decide. >> I'll ask you and you can determine whether you
think there's honesty and integrity in the coverage that he's
And [clears throat] that is the fundamental issue. There's I've
I've obviously got an issue with the there like a couple things
Nicholas has done that are just like pretty egregious. The supporting
the what the DMCA takedowns of clips.
Uh, what else is there? Obviously the lawsuits. Obviously the
lawsuits are crazy. And I do believe Nick's response to those
lawsuits has been like totally
it makes no sense with what his like general opinion has been,
right? How he's felt about like this, like chilling descent,
chilling crit uh critical speech before this. So yeah, I I feel
like I'm just trying to do the quick hits on this to be like,
"No, I I think there's every reason to believe that >> just
like endless obvious hypocrisies like um
Ethan using Dan as an attack dog when they all used toing cry
about Ethan using Brit Bong as an attack dog. There's um the
denim [__] how he covers Denim's total Ethan's total
li."
>> nobody would be confused about this, okay? Nobody's
nobody could possibly be >> and then every single person
you talk to has a completely false impression of it.
>> They would just say things that just like provably false
and you can run the conversation down 100 times over and have
literally everyone say the exact same things every time.
>> Yeah, exactly. >> Did you watch Nicholas Dioro?
Yeah.
>> It's crazy to me like how powerful that kind of thing
is. Like you just see so many people like misreading the exact
same situation the exact same way.
>> You don't you don't really I I don't really expect that.
By the way, do you need another summon?
>> Yeah, I died.
I don't know if this comes through for >> this thing that
he and others do where it's like, well, you farm this and you
farm that, you farm this and you farm that. Yeah, farming isn't
the problem. It's the way that you farm it and whether you do
it with honesty and integrity. And the thing is, maybe Nicholas
is honest and has integrity with his coverage, but the problem
is he won't let anyone challenge him on it in an actual conversation.
Why didn't you say that before? I've said to Nicholas repeatedly
that I've got some issue with his coverage on certain topics,
but it's never been enough for me to make a big [__]
meal out of. But apparently he felt differently and he did want
to make a big meal out of it, but only when I was away on holiday,
so I couldn't respond straight away cuz [__] Okay,
he wanted to wait until I was away so he didn't have to deal
with the immediate blowback of me talking about him cuz now he
can just ignore me and go, "Well, I've dealt with that now and
I'm just another person that's backstabbed him or
He's a hyper sensitive coward. He's conflict avoidant. I could
be conflict avoidant. I'm not even saying I'm innocent of being
conflict avoidant in all of this. Okay. But he relies on >> one
might say that's how this got to this situation. One one could
maybe say >> a friendship with you in order to you know
make you feel bad about >> that's that's what when I was
talking about how you know somebody says I'm just too nice. That's
normally what they actually mean. It's like I'm actually just
very conflict avoidant. I've been too nice and I say that. Okay.
I'm conflict avoidant obviously.
Uh maybe just about everybody's like that to some extent. There's
some some amount of conflict avoidance is required to be like
a socially welladjusted person, but >> you know, >> even
taking a couple of shots at him publicly over his coverage of
a topic. It's ridiculous, bro. It's it's just it's wretched.
It's totally [__] wretched, dude. Dude, there are
other creators that I've had
>> very robust, very robust disagreements with and we've
been totally fine afterwards. We've hopped on stream. >> We've
argued about something. We've even maybe fallen out in the course
of the conversation in some >> What's that?
Nothing actually changed back fashion. >> But things have
been totally fine afterwards. But not so with Nicholas. In fact,
Nicholas doesn't even want to have the [__] conversation.
He wants to wait till you're away and then get some jabs in,
burn the bridge, and then go, "Well, I've dealt with that now,
so I don't need to worry about that anymore. It's dealt with,
>> you know, it's very transparent." And >> and then
he doesn't have to worry about being challenged on this that
he's doing ever because anyone that ever represents that they've
got an issue with it, he'll find a way to eventually cut them
off. I suppose Nick's big point was the conversation being on
a channel. He saw he was farming him. Um, sorry. Um, [clears throat]
did you guys ever watch Ogie show?
Did you guys ever watch Orgie's show? Like, this is the thing,
bro. Commenty's just changed. Comment changed and people don't
want to have conversations anymore.
And that's fine. But then when I say, "Well, why not get on a
stream and talk about it?" You were just farming them for content.
We f Dude, we used to farm each other for content all the time,
bro. I used to talk to Nicholas regularly. I talked to Augie
a little bit. I used to talk to Woody Mack regularly.
And it's fine if you don't like someone and don't want to talk
to them. Fair enough. But this ridiculous idea that it's like
farming someone to get on a [__] stream with them
when it's just a common way that you deal with disagreements
and issues in this space.
Of course. And this is this guy such a queer dude. This is little
strategy now. Sat in his discord of droolians. Oh. Oh, I could
tell this was content as soon as he started telling me how much
he respected me. Lol.
Chud's mad he's losing subs. Someone clipped all the times I
talked about him and I think it was like 22 minutes
Dude, it's wretched, bro. He just sits there in his pathetic
little safe space of drooling commentary viewers that him
>> H Nicholas seething in the Discord will never not be
funny. >> He just said pathetic pathetic. >> I could
tell this was content as soon as he started telling me how much
he respected me.
sat here watching seething seething about the coverage here.
Oh, I only spoke about you for 22 minutes. Yeah, those 22 minutes
at a time when I was on holiday and you know I won't be had a
respond straight away. You coward me
trying to act like he's not watching when he's obviously sat
there. We have a conversation though. Won't have a conversation
because that's content. That's farming someone for content which
is apparently bad now. Loser man. Ridiculous. Ridiculous dude.
[__]
Sounds like you're the mad one,
bro. [laughter] Dude, look at this guy. Look at this dude. This
segment has no gas. I missed like the first 45 minutes, but I
think this will just be a nice clean break between our communities.
How convenient, bro. I manipulated to keep me silent, bro. Dude,
this guy is such a
Dude, the point is what this guy does. He doesn't want to have
a public conversation. And I'm I'm happy to have a public conversation
about stuff, but he leans into that. He leans into that and he'll
send you a little message and try and have a private little conversation
to smooth things over and then you move forward and you just
don't talk about it again.
That's his strategy, bro. That's but that's why he does this
little thing where he reaches out to you. He sends you a little
message, wants to make sure that you're still on side. You're
not going to [__] turn on him.
And then he waits. You go away on holiday and then talk and then
when you come back and respond, it's well, it's just content.
That's a nice clean little break. Doesn't want to be challenged.
Doesn't want to talk about it on stream. Pathetic. Pathetic,
dude.
Pathetic. Anyway,
so yeah, that's the reality. That's what's happened here. Nick
has had a problem with me for months and months and months, okay?
And then at the first opportunity when he thinks I'm not going
to respond, okay,
and comes out with a stream segment talking [__]
about me, right, [laughter] dude? Oh my god, dude. No way. Uhoh.
It's not a safe space. Your friends put a bot on my server and
put my paid Discord on a public website. Oh my god, dude. Stop
stealing his screenshot. Discord screenshots now. Stop stealing
his Discord screenshots, dude. What the Dude, this is unbelievable,
bro. Come, Dude, what happened to this guy? What happened to
this guy, dude? WHAT HAPPENED TO THIS GUY?
intellectual property.
Yeah, I will say also
there were there were like links to this Discord apparently that
didn't require a Patreon
>> I've seen this. I've verified this. >> Didn't
didn't accounts have to be manually approved by a moderator to
be allowed into the Discord.
>> Is that a thing that they had to be manually approved?
I'm just saying that I don't think he ever had like a thing where
he was guaranteeing that people were paying money somehow like
like >> well I I think I think the idea was that it was
manually approved by by a moderator. I think I think you can
get in there. I think even if you get a link say from um a YouTube
community post where you post a link um
>> if you got in there I think you couldn't you actually
couldn't ask for like proof of payment or something. Is that
the >> I doubt it. I doubt it.
or were they just basically like approving anyone who I I I do
wonder
I do wonder and it sounds like if that's the case then that's
mostly on Nicholas's mods is what you're saying
>> I would say so I would say Nicholas order his mod team
if that sort of thing's happening
>> I would also say
that that site was managed by a huge Nicholas Yorio fan and I've
never seen anybody prove otherwise so it's weird that his fandom
did that and then he blames it on Chud's fandom.
>> it's very true.
>> This is not the same Nicholas Dioro that I became friends
with. Maybe you think that's cope. Maybe you think that's cope.
Okay, but come on, dude. There's no way Nicholas Dioro from 2024
acts like this. This is ridiculous, bro. There's no way. There's
no way, dude. The John Wick of commentary, the John Wick of commentary
crying about people screenshotting his members Discord.
>> Pathetic, dude. Absolutely pathetic. And to be honest
with you, yeah, it does. >> Oh, I'm haven't had friends
that you thought, you know, you liked and you could get on with
and you could have disagreements with. >> Turns out that's
not the case. They've not liked you for months. >> But
I'm glad the band-aid is off now. >> We can stop the silly
song and dance. We don't have to do this silly game where you
act like you're my friend so you can keep tabs on me and make
sure that I don't [__] turn on you. >> Dude,
it's so [__] wretched, man. Oh my god, dude. It's
pathetic. Totally pathetic behavior. But people think it's based
somehow. I don't understand. I don't get it. How is this based?
How is moaning about people's screenshot on your Discord server?
How is that like the base thing to do now in commentary apparently?
So, yes, it is unfortunate to have another friend part ways with
>> It's more unfortunate that they choose to do it in a
way that they, you know, line up their attack with you going
on holiday so they can do it without getting immediate blowback
and then act like it's dealt with and you've moved on and that's
it.
But in some ways, in some ways it's good to band off. Just show
the best of your Nick saying Tom held the video for a week, please.
Oh, wait. What? You mean this message? I called Tom early on,
told him my terms on what needed to be fake for us to maintain
a friendship. He assured me he was innocent while allegations
were still dropping. I heard talks of the phone call he leaked
and what was inside of it. I watched his completed video on January
27th.
I planned to stream it Friday, but she kept accusing Tom of more.
I think that was why it was delayed. I checked in with Tom Monday
and asked when is it dropping because I hadn't heard past him.
He said now. The video, my understanding, unchanged on the 27th.
So, wait. The video was ready on the 27th and then it was unchanged
for a week and then got released. Is that right? The Tuesday
before I left, bro. What? What? So, there's that whole week of
streaming doesn't get released and then it get just so happens
to get released on the first day that I'm away,
bro. These
waited for me to go away, didn't they? It's so obvious, bro.
They waited for me to go away before releasing it. Oh my god,
dude. That is ridiculous, bro. And I'm the snake apparently.
And I'm the [__] snake.
What the [__] dude? And you know why that is, don't
you? It's so we can do his little gay Oh, you're sweeping but
not covering it straight away. As if that was my point,
dude. Okay, this is the clip that you want me to play. You want
to play this clip? >> Oh, wait. Before you get there, I
want to just explain this. We always get accused of running gay
ops, right, Tom? We get accused of like being a commentary cabal
who just never has that been more true than this story. Okay,
[laughter] cuz we were in a group chat, right? And we were like,
BWC, you're dropping on Monday. Tom, when are you going? I think
I'm going to drop mine on Tuesday. Okay, you you drop on Tuesday,
Tom. I'll drop on Wednesday. Uh cuz I use that information he
gave to film an interview at Colossal Enslaza to debunk it before
they even put it out. Bob Blacks Twitter versus on Thursday.
Everyone, we're going to go to Auggie on Friday. Uh that was
the most coordinated thing the commentary community has ever
done. But the reason why we did it is because he was bragging
about how much fun he was going to have in Los Angeles. So we
wanted to up his vacation. So we put a video out every single
day. So what Vegas is talking about where he's like, [laughter]
>> "Was that the goal of [__] my vacation?
I had a great time." So it didn't work. Unfortunately, I had
a wonderful time. So, I don't know if that was the plan, but
I had a great time. >> Yo, did you see Nick just dropped
the video? That was like the second bomb. You go ask anybody
who was in VidCon 2019. They'll tell you there was a story where
I'm Alex is walking around with a thousand yard stair like a
bomb just went off and he's like, "What is going on?" He's just
walking around the party. Ask Willie. Apparently, he bought him
a beer and then put out a video called I'm Alex is the biggest
douchebag when he got off the plane when he got home. >> I
remember I remember um I think it was like Nick you dropped a
picture like I had one and then you dropped the interview. Dude,
these guys are like actually the [__] we actually
like Willie went up to his face and pretended to be friendly
and like bought him a beer and then after he dropped a video
on how much of a scumbag he is. >> Isn't it awesome just
knowing that Nick got like totally bullied at Tom's VidCon party?
Isn't that just awesome knowing that happened this year at VidCon?
>> Is that like bullied for his girlfriend, right? Wasn't
that the thing? No, no, he got bullied. Uh,
>> some other YouTuber went over and stole his glasses
and made fun of him and >> Oh, right.
well, I'm sure I'm sure, you know,
I feel like he's winning. You know, he's got a lot of pinball
machines. I feel like he's not doing so bad. You know, >> he
met Billy Mitchell machines. >> Is that cool? Yeah, he's
got a he's got a bunch of pinball machines and stuff >> he
spent like three years mindlessly saying Billy Mitchell was like
the worst guy ever cuz he loved Carl Jobs videos and then K jobs
got raped and he was like oh
>> wait like Nicholas like totally flipped as soon as public
opinion flipped on somebody. That sounds like
>> I don't think that could be true. That doesn't sound
like Nicholas D. did no >> I know. >> Went with the
wave,
supported some for ages, and then flipped when the tide changed.
Wait, >> No. No. That could be the Nicholas Dioro. I know.
There's no way. There's no way.
I'm going to hellfire. So, you better get aggro. I'm going to
I'm going to die if you don't get aggro. Oh, I'm dead. Thank
you. Thank you. Thank you. Good one, bro. Good one. Good one.
Good one. I just want to hellfire some dudes and you can't even
hold aggros. So up, bro. >> Nope. Do I want to say is the
way? >> No, the interview was my video. Um, >> was
it Did you have a video like before that that was about it without
the >> That was before I met Alex, but that was like a
That was like a month earlier, right? You went and you dropped
the first video, I dropped my video, and then you dropped a follow-up
on Hiojan when she started dating. >> So, it was timed
so that they could [__] with me. That's the reality,
isn't it? That's what I'm understanding here. There's no cabal,
guys. There's no cabal. Okay. Don't you dare say anything about
sweeping her a cabal, but they will work together to release
a video at a time to [__] with Chud logic
What's the response to that? The video was ready a week before
I went away or six six five or six days before I went away. And
I'm the snake apparently. Bro, do you know what's so [__]
stupid about this? Me and Nicholas talked about all this extensively
when the Turkey Tom allegations were happening. We had two arguments
about it. We had two arguments about it, dude. At any point he
could have spoken about anything he wanted because all the stuff
that he used and talked about was stuff that was already available.
There was no new content because I was on holiday because [laughter]
I wasn't responding to the video straight away cuz I was away
new content to make it
>> Oh, that didn't even show up for me. That showed up
for you guys. >> Oh, you just picked it up. Damn. >> It's
okay.
>> Nice. fell steel gloves.
>> Little, you know, segment about me. It was all stuff
that was already out there. That's about I'm Alex, by the way.
Yeah, that's not about me. That's about I'm Alex. The clip is
about I'm Alex and someone has presented it as in like, oh, look,
they've done this sort of thing before. So, they like did the
same thing with you where they've coordinated it to release it
in a way where you're away. They hope to [__] with
your vacation and it allows them to run certain narratives or
something. So, here's the thing. Here's the thing. Okay, here's
the thing. A lot of this is just petty nonsense and Okay. and
mad me calling him a sweeper trying to respond whatever a lot
of his right the thing that I found most frustrating and most
irritating about all of this is this kind of bizarre credibility
attack that people have tried to make on me because I'm willing
to like have a laugh let a lot of things slide but the idea that
Turkey Tom's response somehow undermined my credibility because
I don't know what I was validating the allegations saying they
were true or something like that and now he's disproven them
what else do we have oh I was going to go look up the Dorio tweets
right throw away. Could throw away real quick.
I don't want to watch I don't want to watch the clips of this.
Okay. Nicholas Yorio says Chudlo Logic made up an insane theory.
Chloic thinks that Turkey Tom was going to delay his YouTube
video that could redeem him just so over Chudlo Logic's vacation.
He thinks it's a big Cabal conspiracy.
Yeah, cuz you guys have done that
Cuz you guys literally talked about doing that. Nicholas tells
that story in private, too. Just so you know. I've I heard that
story before anyone told he tells that story in private as well,
but I'm Alex. >> The TBYS video is absolutely rancid. If
you haven't seen it, I'm gonna play the intro, but it is one
of the most insane demonic crackpipe theories I've ever seen
in my life. The only time I've heard a bigger cracked theory
than the one that was here. >> Oh, I think uh I do think
that I forgot to play this clip of this guy saying that Teeone
told him to go watch the Think Before You Sleep video.
Oh, which is just
>> is that Chud Logic thinks that Turkey Tom was going
to delay his YouTube video that could redeem him.
>> Just so it would over Chud's vacation that Tom would
risk like his multi-million dollar YouTube channel
specifically to slight a guy who's going to get 15k views on
his VOD. That's crack. But this is also crack.
Save his YouTube channel. His YouTube channel is going to be
fine. Either case, YouTube channel is always going to be fine.
What's up? You're back. >> Yeah, cool. There was that the
only Nicholas Yoro video. There's only one one clip from tonight
of him seething about Chud. That's it.
>> That's too bad. >> There are a couple There are
a couple in my uh Discord in my farm channel. I
>> there were two.
>> Give me a second.
Give me a second. Give me a second. Give me a second.
Where are we looking here? We're looking
Where's my queen in Discord? There it
Are these still going to be here? Let's see. Nick responds to
Chud,
>> guys. I don't think that Nick cares about Chud's video,
which is great. All right, so just to address this, Chud didn't
release like a video on me. Uh Chud took I think Chud's editor,
DK, clipped his two-hour crybaby rant. Thankfully, this is probably
why it took so long to upload. So it was right before I was streaming.
I think it took them that long to cut it down to a 40minute crybaby
rant. >> Year. The best commentator of the year.
>> Okay, I will say there's a lot of fat to cut off of
that that overall segment, but it was really well edited. Like
they cut it down. I'm I'm happy I waited for the DK edit. >> I
mean, to be fair, a lot of it I assume you me watch some of it
through my stream. A lot of it was uh not actually the segment.
It was Chud doing his like, you know, his opening where he's
just sitting there talking, responding to chat. He does politics
or whatever. >> Wait for people to roll in >> because
everyone's coming in talking about Nick. He obviously starts
talking about it sort of like vaguely >> at first, but
he's actually not saying it. He's basically saying the same saying
three lines on repeat for like 30 minutes until he gets into
the segment starts leaking.
>> Actually, I didn't see a lot of your stuff. All I saw
was at some point Ch does start and you go, "Wait, what is this?
Just the START OF THE SEGMENT?" I remember that part. >> Yeah,
[laughter]
>> that was funny. >> What's the over under for her
viewers? More Ian or less? >> Thank you. Yeah, I think
uh Ana might pull more.
>> That's P. No, but I think for the Tread Logic thing,
Can I say something to you, >> Jesus Christ. >> I
really like you. >> Thank you. >> Yeah, they clipped
his 2-hour crybaby rant down to a 40-minute crybaby rant. And
honestly, I think that the best thing I could possibly say is
I fully endorse you just going to watch it. I think if you sit
down and you actually enjoy the video in front of you,
hopefully they cut out a lot of the points where HE WAS SCREAMING,
"WHY AM I MALICIOUS? I'M NOT MALICIOUS. WHAT ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT, MATE?
WELL, HOW WHAT PART OF THIS is >> I do think DK unfortunately
cut the part where Chud called Nicholas a pig, little piggy Nicholas
or something and then
pretty gratuitously. I do think they unfortunately cut that part.
That was very funny. I enjoyed that. Um, that's too bad. >> MALICIOUS.
I WENT ON VACATION. If they cut out a lot of that, it might actually
be somewhat watchable. But the version that I watched, not watchable.
So maybe you might have better mileage, but I think if you go
and watch it, you'll find out very quickly that everything I
said he was going to do was true. So my recommendation is
wait,
you explicitly burn the bridge with this guy and then go, I bet
he's going to get real mad when he comes back. Oh, look, he got
real mad when he came back. What a great prediction.
That's an incredible prediction. Who could have possibly predicted
that? >> Was just watching it. >> You're on Twitch.
I've heard nothing but
>> uh No.
>> Okay. I I want to say I was thinking that anyway. I
thought >> things for the people who've already seen it.
[laughter] >> And it kind of creeped me out a bit to be
honest. So I am
>> Okay. All right. All right. And then
>> part twoing. WHY AM I MALICIOUS? I'M NOT MALICIOUS.
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT, >> It's the same [__]
>> What part of this is malicious?
>> Fair enough. Fair enough. Fair enough. Fair enough.
>> I wear an XL, okay? Cuz I'm a big fella, right? I wear
an XL, European size XL. You go over there, right? And they're
much smaller, okay?
They're much smaller. So you're like, "Oh, XL." They're like,
"No, no, no, not XL. Not XL." Cuz they know you're a fat
And so you got to buy like a four or five XL Asian size.
and you're just like really but there are some places you can
go to
like there's a H&M for example in Shanghai in the one of
the malls that sells European
because the Asians are that much smaller
you know dude [laughter] dude I know dude
look dude right
because over there everyone's very slim if you're a roton westerner
you're sort of seen as like a bit of an oddity And on top of
that as well, you've got the happy Buddha and it's good luck
to rub the happy Buddha's belly.
So when I went on this like Hallong Bay cruise, right, one of
the waiters kept coming up to me and rubbing my belly,
It was it was fine. It was funny. I thought it was funny. [snorts]
But he was more of my belly for luck, I think, or something like
that.
Oh, look, white man. Big belly me long time.
It was a male. It was a guy. It was a
>> dude. I
>> It was a guy. It wasn't anything weird about it. He
was just having a laugh.
I thought it was funny.
Dude, I did I gave a cash to the cruise afterwards because it
was it was good
Mira long time. [laughter]